Okay, who would you rather
have go down on you?
Michael Buble
or Janet Jackson?
Oh, okay.
What Buble are we
talking about, though?
I don't know, the optimal
Michael Buble.
His weight fluctuates.
Yeah.
So does hers.
So does mine.
Yeah.
But then again,
Michael Buble is,
like, such a crooner.
I feel like he could do
stuff with his mouth that,
like, most people
couldn't.
Somebody call
a locksmith?
Yeah.
I'm gonna look disgusting
for tonight is all.
No, you're gonna
look hot and cool.
Your shower is just
a lockpick away.
Very hot.
Very cool.
What's your name,
sweetheart?
Uh...
Yolanda.
So where is it
you sleep?
What?
Which apartment's yours?
Um...
Do you have any, like,
credentials?
Or, like, a license to be
a locksmith that you could
just show us?
No, the only thing you
need to be a locksmith is
you gotta want it.
Real bad.
That one.
Yeah, it's this one,
the 6--
6C.
(amorous groaning)
They call this
a whore door.
'Cause it's so easy.
Okay.
Thank you for your
terrifying services
and don't call us,
we'll call you.
Oh yeah.
Oh, you'll call me, huh?
(whistling)